how long can I stay on my parents health
insurance that's next year
how much you spend on alcohol like a
week
okay I have to say
I've got my money oh I you know what
just give me till next Friday I'll have
it for you
Stephen
[Music]
No
ah my lucky red hat Lena's whistle
[Music]
carpet day I make a dentist appointment
can do it for me
what is our family medical history
[Music]
do your thing robot
can we just stay in tonight yeah that
sounds good very perfect
I want a boy-girl party mm-hmm with
mingling mmm I want to close the
restaurant and invite my whole class
over though and I want there to be a
deejay and dancing and a smoke machine
how do you cook rice how do you soften
but how do I saw a chicken unplug that
clock boy you can't tell town when you
sleep it's 2 cents an ounce
[Music]
here are the coupons coupons are for
poor people yes like us
[Music]
my day we had plenty of fun just
throwing rocks at each other
big bag dirt clods that's what the kids
want
[Music]
being grown-up doesn't mean not having
fun it's actually tons of funds in which
wine
[Music]
[Music]